[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad vamos a chile que está
viviendo un proceso político y social
histórico recordemos que en mayo los
chilenos eligieron a los 155
representantes de la denominada
convención constituyente encargada de
redactar la nueva constitución del país
que va a reemplazar al actualmente
vigente desde la dictadura de augusto
pinochet estamos hablando de un órgano
que se caracteriza principalmente por la
diversidad tiene la representación de
género paritaria también una importante
cantidad de miembros que son
independientes representantes además de
pueblos originarios y también del
colectivo el gti kumasi saludamos a
elisa loncón ella es precisamente la
presidenta de la convención
constituyente de chile esta activista
mapuche profesora y lingüista elisa
loncón muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
pasó ya a poco más de un mes desde la
instalación de la convención
constituyente que usted misma preside ya
están de hecho las comisiones trabajando
qué balance hace de este mes
es una es un balance que tiene como todo
balance elementos de logros
y tiene también dificultades
dentro de los logros bueno usted ya
hablo
de las comisiones y para nosotros eso
significa el tema de la instalación de
la convención porque este órgano no
existía sino que hubo que instalarlo
darle una institucionalidad básica que
nos permitiera trabajar
y darle también dotarlo de un sistema de
organización
la organización implica establecer
[Música]
pronto
definiciones para organizar la
participación
para organizar la toma de palabras de un
sistema de votación que nos permita
tomar las decisiones
un sistema también que tiene que ver con
el
aparato
a electrónico que nos permita votar
también la distancia
entonces implican condiciones técnicas
en el tema de lo que más
tal vez lo más difícil fue
poder
lograr una colaboración directa
contribuciones tal vez con él
con el gobierno con el aparato ya
instalado no hemos tenido una buena
colaboración con el gobierno al
contrario el trabajo siempre ha sido
de alguna manera poco
así ha sido un poco elaboradora del
gobierno con la conversión
constitucional
elisa cuente nuevos cuál es el enfoque
principal y en qué temas se quieren
centrar en la constituyente
nosotros como ustedes ya saben hemos
instalado
el tema de la paridad que sea una
constitución escrita de manera paritaria
con todo nivel con participación para
paritaria e incluso en la toma de
palabras nos estamos
cuidando de que se refleje la paridad no
podemos darle solamente a un grupo la
palabra sino que tiene que ser
igualitaria es un tema fundamental pero
el tema de paridad también se ha
profundizado y discutido que esa paridad
no significa binaria pueden puede haber
paridad no binaria y de hecho nosotros
las mujeres tenemos una larga
trayectoria de colaboración
de parís paritaria no binaria y sobre
todo en la raíz la relación de los
cuidados sea una madre con una nieta las
madres con las abuelas etcétera han
hecho todo como para en colaboración
para poder trabajar y sacar la familia
adelante entonces también hay una
discusión ahí en términos de naciones
originarias buscamos que esta
constitución sea plurinacional es decir
que reconozca a las naciones originarias
preexistente al estado donde en la
nación chilena es una más de las tantas
naciones que existen en este territorio
eso implica reconocimiento de derechos
colectivos
reconocimientos políticos a la
autodeterminación y de la autonomía
ahora la manera es se va a ver cómo se
hace como en qué va a consistir eso pero
la grandes línea ya está o sea ya están
en el curso no es que esté definida
el tema de la pluralidad lingüística
cultural porque chileno es monolingüe no
es mono cultural en términos de las
diversidades tenemos las diversidades de
las regiones que todas las regiones
aparezcan representadas y considerados
sus derechos en términos de
descentralización y también todo lo que
tiene que ver con la diversidad sexual
en las comunidades
más de identidad lesbiana homosexual y
toda la otra cama de tristeza y también
se suma a este proceso como la niñez y
la adolescencia va también quedar
protegidos sus ellos como sujetos de
derechos son temas que están y se están
instalando y que nos va a dar una ruta
para para dónde orientar la discusión se
está también trabajando o sea y se ha
instalado a nivel del discurso de que el
estado tiene que ser un estado solidario
que garantice derechos sociales más que
un estado
neoliberal como hoy día
se ha desarrollado y hemos tenido hasta
la fecha partida de la constitución de
la dictadura de augusto pinochet el tema
del neoliberalismo ha sido profundamente
discutido porque a medida de que el
tiempo pasa las restricciones de los
derechos humanos fundamentales son cada
vez peores y al mismo tiempo el tema de
la exploración de la madre tierra es
está dejando sin biodiversidad bueno los
pueblos indígenas también incorporamos
el derecho los derechos de la madre
tierra y cómo se van a incorporar eso
también en materia de discusión en la en
el proceso ya discusión de contenido que
les hablemos ahora de los mensajes
culturales sociales y también políticos
no de la transformación que representa
la constitución de a todos estos niveles
verdad
los mensajes culturales y la presencia
web por un lado la presencia hay mucha
presencia
femenina
estamos en paridad
tenemos
muchos los convencionales también hay
una fuerte presencia de convencionales
jóvenes personas jóvenes
y adultos jóvenes
es decir para ser más preciso y que son
de diferentes sectores
de sectores sociales
como lo es la mayoría del pueblo de
chile
yo no lo hubiera no lo pudiera ver desde
el punto de vista social de son sectores
más de clase media y baja
que vienen de islas que vienen de
lugares lejanos de chile y que nunca
antes tuvimos todos nadie de nosotros la
posibilidad de conversar en torno a una
nueva constitución entonces esa
diversidad se refleja en la manera como
se visten como están
y los pueblos originarios o nosotros
llegamos aquí también con un
planteamiento de derecho y de dignidad
queremos ser aceptado con nuestros
trajes con nuestras lenguas con nuestra
filosofía con nuestra manera de entender
la tierra entonces en este primer mes de
aniversario
instalamos todas las banderas de las
regiones de las diversidades y también
de los pueblos originarios porque para
para dar esa señal que chile tiene color
que chile tiene mensaje que tiene otro
tipo de manera de interrelacionar de
relacionarse en la sociedad
y por otro lado también las lenguas
originarias porque no es chile
monolingüe aquí chile el
plurilingüismo sorich in arias y la
fuerza de las lenguas originarias es que
llevan también el pensamiento originario
y en el fondo llevan valores que no
están instalados desde un pensamiento
eurocéntrico sino que desde acá desde
esta tierra que se ha convenido todas
estas habitantes que han convivido todo
el tiempo con una naturaleza que no es
europea va sino que es como el chile es
como la describió administrar como la
describe todo neruda se fija entonces
esos somos los los chilenos tenemos
diversidades y es por eso que iguale
esta vez hizo es la ceremonia de la
pachamama porque es el mes de la
pachamama de y la ceremonia lo hicieron
los convencionales de los pueblos aimara
que he hecho
y caranta y de los pueblos del norte
y qué significa para usted deslice hacer
la mujer mapuche que estaba presidiendo
un órgano tan importante
es un honor para el pueblo mapuche
más que lo personal para mí es para el
pueblo mapuche es para las mujeres
mapuche es para los niños y las niñas de
mi pueblo
y eso es una señal importante porque si
el pueblo lo pueblo originario hemos
sido injustamente juzgado
y la verdad que este reconocimiento que
nos hizo nos hicieron los los
convencionales no indígenas por votar
por nosotros
refleja de que todo chile quiere ver un
chile distinto un chile de
hermandad de solidaridad con chile
intercultural a un chile plural
y está en el corazón creo de los
diferentes sectores de los pueblos
originarios entonces es un desafío
también muy grande porque desde el mundo
mapuche tengo que pensar es
garantizar ese chile diverso y no
quedarme en el mundo solo del mapuche
sino poder entender desde ahí que la
otra diversidad también debe dictar que
los otros discursos también deben entrar
que los otros del otro tienen que entrar
dignamente con nosotros en un trabajo
intercultural enorme que bueno espero
que que pueda ser la clave para
proyectar este nuevo esta nueva
constitución
elisa loncón muchísimas gracias por
haber sido parte de la entrevista de
france 24 a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]